I'd like to read you a short statement
yesterday Saturday the 20th of June sure
a short time after 7:00 p.m. a man ran
into four brie Gardens in the center of
Redding and attacked members of the
public with a knife he left three dead
and a number of people needing hospital
treatment this was an atrocity my
deepest sympathies go out to the
families who will be mourning loved ones
today after this horrific act and to
everyone who has been affected by it
we're working with the coroner to
formally identify all those who have
died and to inform and support their
relatives
I'd like to praise the actions of Thames
Valley Police colleagues who responded
immediately and they detained the
attacker nearby unarmed and incredibly
brave tribute to the bravery of members
of the public who provided emergency
first aid policy counterterrorism
policing officers also attended the
scene immediately and they have worked
through the night very closely with
Thames Valley Police and this morning I
can formally confirm that this was
declared a terrorist incidents at 8:30
as a result of those investigations
through the night a 25 year old man was
arrested yesterday on suspicion of
murder
and he remains in custody from our
inquiries undertaken so far officers
have found nothing to suggest that there
was anyone else involved in this attack
and presently we are not looking for
anyone else in relation to the incident
however counterterrorism detectives work
closely with the security services and
will work closely with Thames Valley
major crime colleagues and we continue
to make inquiries to ensure that that is
the case our priority will always be to
ensure there is no outstanding threat to
members of the public
although the motivation for this
horrific act is far from certain
counterterrorism placing have taken
responsibility for leading the
investigation however we're clear that
it was not associated in any way with
the black lives matter protest which
took place peacefully earlier on in the
day
and which had concluded some hours
before this attack took place we will be
working around the clock on this
investigation to get justice for those
killed and injured and I would appeal to
members of the public who may have
witnessed the attack or have information
that might assist the investigation to
contact the police I am incredibly
grateful to the 41 witnesses who come
forward so far but if you have not yet
come forward please call us and
particularly if you have any footage of
the incident and on that point can I
reiterate calls for the public to show
restraint and please don't share images
and footage of the attack on social
media we are asking CSPs to do exactly
the same thing the pandemic has made
very strange territory of our familiar
places and I appreciate the concern this
attack will obviously cause but let me
be clear there is no specific
intelligence to suggest that anyone
attending crowded places is at risk but
I would ask the public please continue
in your daily lives but be alert not
alarmed when you are out in public if
you see anything suspicious anything at
all that makes you feel suspicious then
please report it please remain vigilant
as I said we're going to work
round-the-clock investigating this
incident we will issue further
information as it's confirmed thank you